Three reasons why we should
stop using nuclear energy.
One nuclear weapons proliferation nuclear
technology made a violent entrance
onto the world stage just one year after
the world's first ever nuclear test
explosion in 1944 to large cities were
destroyed by just two single bombs after
that, react to technology slowly evolved
as a means of generating electricity,
but it's always been intimately connected
with nuclear weapons technology.
It's nearly impossible to develop nuclear
weapons without access to react to
technology.
In fact,
the Nuclear Nonproliferation Treaty serves
the purpose of spreading the nuclear
reactor technology without spreading
nuclear weapons with limited success.
In 40 years.
Five countries have developed their
own weapons with the help of react to
technology.
The fact of the matter is that it can
be very hard to distinguish a covert
nuclear weapons program from the
peaceful use of nuclear energy.
In the 1970s the big nuclear powers were
happily selling peaceful technology to
smaller countries,
which then developed weapons of their own.
The road to deadly nuclear weapons is
always paved with peaceful reactors to
nuclear waste and pollution.
Spent.
Nuclear fuel is not only radioactive
but also contains extremely poisonous
chemical elements and like plutonium,
it loses its harmfulness only slowly
over several tens of thousands of years.
And there is also a process
called reprocessing,
which means the extraction of
plutonium from spent nuclear fuel.
It can be used for two purposes to build
nuclear weapons or to use it as new
fuel,
but hardly any of it is used as fuel
because we don't have the right kind of
reactors for that.
A milligram will kill you.
A few kilograms make an atomic bomb
and even an inconspicuous country like
Germany literally has tons of the staff
just lying around because reprocessing
sounded like a good idea decades ago
and where we'll all the waste go after
dumping it into the ocean was forbidden.
We've tried to bury it,
but we can't find a place where
it will definitely stay secure.
For tens of thousands of years,
over 30 countries have
rate nearly 400 reactors,
managing several hundred thousands of
tons of nuclear waste and only one is
currently serious about
opening a permanent civilian
way storage, tiny Finland,
three accidents and disasters.
Over 60 years of nuclear power.
You said there have been
seven major accidents in
reactors or facilities dealing
with nuclear waste.
Three of those were mostly contained,
but four of them released significant
amounts of radioactivity into the
environment.
In 1957 1987 and 2011 large
areas of land in Russia,
Ukraine, and Japan were rendered unfit
for human habitation for decades to come.
The number of deaths is highly disputed,
but probably lies in the thousands.
These disasters happened with nuclear
reactors are very different types in very
different countries and several
decades apart. Looking at the numbers,
we may as well ask ourselves,
oh,
10% of the world's energy supply
worth a devastating disaster.
Every 30 years worth 30% be worth
another Fukushima or Chernobyl,
somewhere on earth every 10 years.
What area would have to be contaminated?
So we say no more.
Where is the line?
So should we use nuclear energy?
The risks may outweigh the benefits and
maybe we should stop looking into this
direction and drop this technology for
good. If you want to hear the other side,
the argument or a short
introduction to nuclear energy,
click here and our
channel has a new sponsor,
audible.com if you use the
URL audible.com/nutshell
you can get a free audio
book and support our channel.
Producing our videos takes a lot of time
and we fill a lot of us by listening to
audiobooks for ready,
entertaining book we recommend
into thin air by Jon Krakauer.
He's a great writer and the story
is really absorbing and true.
Go to audible.com/nutshell
to get the book for free.
Thanks a lot to audible for supporting
our channel and to you for watching.